you
put that in your pipe and smoke a
[__] Uncle Joe here Monday
January 23rd the day the devil was
buried at sea it's your day to sling
dick and take hostages and stab him in
the [__] eye boss
Uncle Joe here I did not go to March
Madonna blowing up [__] White House
is telling people [__] you who gives a
[__]
all these little simple [__] Gentiles
when she said [__] you oh my god oh my
god go [__] yourself anyway we're here
look we we had a big week we got the
church what's happening now ten nine
eight o'clock
tremendous guest tomorrow night and my
flap is from taped in the [__] hand
of a planet show I'm always going ten
minutes no but if you want to come down
you'll be helping me the [__] out and
beside that that's it I'm shooting this
thing we're gonna be the [__] cat man
and that's it and that's that but
besides that I missed you [__]
I missed you from the bottom Myron you
can't be smoking outside and Tempe you
know they had a heart attack so I
couldn't do dick but trust me I was in
training how to respect for you [__]
savages but Joey enough with the
chitty-chat let's park this [__]
reefer oh [__]
we got this Russian we've delayed the
wreck from Putin it was dropped off by
one of trumps people this is the [__]
that killed Carrie sister Carrie Fisher
the sister the [__] aunt everybody this
is the weed right here but enough is
enough
that refrain your [__] lungs just
generating [__] you know I'm saying let
you know it's [__] Monday [__]
I'm not sitting that's that yeah
my mission it's been a couple days
this is the best part of my day coming
out in don't get me wrong I got up like
a [__] 3:00 in the morning I did some
brightness I sent emails I got my week
quarter I went back to sleep for like
four [__] hours and a little protein
shaker took the baby to school and here
we are you understand me coochie-coo sir
nobody gets [__] in we just got a
little stone and we go back to do what
you were doing I love it that's it I
know much to say today because yeah it's
a cloudy day it's raining I don't give a
[__] I'm still in a sling Dave I don't
give a [__] about trial I don't give a
[__] about glaze and I don't give a [__]
about nobody you got to do what you got
to do with two [__] heads you gotta
dig deep dig deep and safe up all these
little Gentiles crying and [__] I don't
want to be a cry I don't need that
Starbucks I don't need to do what the
[__] they do to be cool that's what they
just do [__] to belittle we're here oh
my god give me a hug - get get the [__]
out of here huh what's wrong with these
[__] you don't need no hugs you
don't need Scientology you want to fill
that hole in your [__] heart reefer
let your imagination take off
you'll see me act Oh playing other
people's tours I don't give a [__] I've
never given a [__] I have never given a
[__] playing the people's tones whatever
they think is funny you think is funny
I'm not on that [__] [__] dog I'm on
my own [__] I suggest you go on
your own
trip till he makes me let get the [__]
out of my face he's about the people of
do anything definitive and at the end of
the day who wants to fit in I want to
fit him I can't fit no way I don't give
a [__] I don't want to say I never said
no way even people tie your Joey Joe
then I've been to the [__] it's a mad
flavor guess what I don't give a [__]
there's a manage that I made them how's
that one for you how's that come on guys
little clouds the [__] bet coming
your way
wakes you up the [__] night a morning
smoking reefer like this like a [__]
Adam
me that's move I don't even know what
this is I just know it's [__] Debbie
it's the triple xpr from sunset or good
googly [__] moogly you pop a few stars
with a couple hits or this it's a
different world out there you understand
me it's a different world out there
it's like hanging out with [__] John
Stowe
I smoked another ball what the [__]
would he learn to 20-under it's Monday
they can't take a joke dump to suck your
dick that's it
it's Monday what do you want from me
half these people are lucky to be
[__] awake walking around had a look
at the kids say gotta follow all the
kids to get to what [__] [__] school
is cuz they don't know everybody's
[__] on the [__] Monday you don't
want to be [__] and a couple these
things and take it easy that's it you
don't got to kill yourself
the most important thing is showing up
[__] if you can't show up you
can't put it together you understand me
you could plump all that [__] you want
but if you don't show up and they ain't
gonna work for you I'm let you know that
right now I'm terrible at everything I
calmly do but I keep showing up
it's a [__] smoke amira trip just
keep showing up and nobody could stop
getting nobody could take it away from
you think about that I'll [__] Monday
you know I'm saying and that's it and
that's that I got [__] to do and people
to see I'm gonna stop with you guys I
gotta go to bleep store pick up my batch
for the week
and that is back onto my dad I'm gonna
write the book a little bit I'm gonna
make some notes on this animal planet
thing and that's it we got the podcast
later o'clock I hope you join us this
evening I'm [__] stoned dog this we've
got some kick to it that [__] got a mule
and I don't know what they [__] dig
something with this [__] weed well
anyway you know I love you you know I
got your back
I'm a Nashville February 2nd to the
fourth couple weeks that's it that's all
I got I'm gonna relax I'm gonna smoke
dope I'm gonna go to jujitsu and I'm
gonna shoot this pilot this week besides
that I love you [__]
stay black take that ass to the hoop and
don't let nobody [__] with you today all
right uncle Joey loves you see you
tonight
eight o'clock same bat-time same
bat-channel